le président de la République à chausser
ses crampons pour discuter la rencontre
du variété Club de France à Poissy un
match face au soignant du centre
hospitalier intercommunal de Poissy et
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme a décidé de nommer
Florian Rousseau au poste de directeur
du programme olympique l'ancien pistard
triple champion olympique aura pour
objectif de faire performer cette équipe
de France en 2024 et l'Open de France de
golf va faire son grand retour à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines après deux
annulations en raison de la crise
sanitaire la compétition aura lieu en
septembre 2022 ça a été officialisé
début novembre un demi mineur de
reverser dans les Yvelines depuis le
début du plan relance il y a 1 ans des
fois on attribue à des entreprises des
associations ou des collectivités en
faveur de l'écologie la compétitivité ou
encore la cohésion des territoires côté
politique à l'érable est élu maire de
Trappes après l'annulation de son
élection pour des manquements aux règles
du code électoral sa liste est arrivé en
tête dès le premier tour avec 58 % des
suffrages plusieurs dommage on était
rendu au professeur
d'histoire-géographie Samuel Paty
victime d'une attaque terroriste l'année
dernière devant le collège de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine les écoles et
viennoise en décider d'honorer sa
mémoire avec des cours des 10 à la
liberté d'expression une marche blanche
ou encore un monument en forme de livre
ouvert Emmanuel Macron est venu
inaugurer la maison Zola à Médan après
10 ans de travaux la maison de
l'écrivain rouvre ses portes elle est
accompagnée d'un musée dédié à l'affaire
Dreyfus l'auteur et compositrice
Catherine Lara s'est vu remettre l'ordre
national du Mérite à Poissy la ville qui
l'a vu naître l'automobile de demain se
prépare dans les Yvelines un nouveau
campus vert pour la recherche et le
développement va s'installer à Poissy la
vente du domaine de Grignon est suspendu
démobilisation avait eu lieu en octobre
pour protester contre cette session du
promoteur immobilier Altaréa Cogedim et
le Skype business 17 encore tenu en
ligne cette année en raison du covid-19
l'objectif développer l'attractivité du
territoire le gouvernement annonce
l'obligation de la troisième dose du
vaccin pour lutter contre la covid-19
pour lutter face à la flûte de demande
plusieurs centre de vaccination rouvre
leur porte comme le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines tu reviens
progressivement à sa capacité maximale
Joséphine Baker et la 6e femme à entrer
au Panthéon mets la première deux
couleurs noir l'artiste
franco-américaine a vécu au Vésinet
d'ailleurs après son intronisation une
table ronde et est organisé dans la
ville en présence de l'un de ses fils en
campagne dans les Yvelines les 5
candidats au congel est républicain en
tenue des meetings à Versailles plaisir
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ou encore
Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est finalement
Valérie Pécresse qui a remporté la
dernière étape du congé avec 60,95 % des
vois la présidente de la région
Île-de-France représentera les
républicains pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 et enfant
plusieurs d'animation avec lui dans les
Yvelines pour récolter des fonds pour le
Téléthon basket tir à l'arc encore
pétanque les villes étaient mobilisés
pour la 35e édition